una amenaza permanente es la evaluación
de las autoridades de ecuador ante la
situación del sistema penitenciario en
la nación un nuevo motín en la cárcel de
el turi ubicada en la ciudad de cuenca
al sur del país dejó muertos heridos y
reos evacuados así como más de 800
efectivos movilizados para solventar la
situación hoy existe la voluntad y vamos
a tomar
las acciones que sean necesarias
aquellos que desprecian la vida tendrán
que entender que viven en un estado de
derecho y tendrán que aprender a
respetar los derechos y las libertades
de todos la angustia se apoderó de los
familiares a las afueras del recinto
carcelario denunciaban llevar horas
esperando y exigiéndole a las
autoridades que detuvieran los
enfrentamientos dentro de las
instalaciones usted como puede ver los
chicos están en el techo pidiendo
auxilio y los señores se encuentran aquí
afuera y amenazándonos con los caballos
porque estamos exigiendo algo justo
desde el año 2020 se han generado 5
amotinamientos que sólo en el 2021
dejaron alrededor de 320 reclusos
fallecidos uno de los más mortíferos se
registró el pasado septiembre en un
penal de la provincia suroccidental de
guayas donde murieron aproximadamente
120 personas según la comisión
interamericana de derechos humanos la
corrupción el abandono estatal y la
ausencia de políticas de seguridad
integral son factores que atraviesan el
sistema penitenciario y que podrían
facilitar este tipo de situaciones en
las cárceles del país